こんにちは
始め車鉄です最後に挑発に社長です
持っていた
いやーもうホラーでしかないなすごいな
これよくで皆さんなぜ私が今こんな体に
なっているかと言うと朝一から私一時間
かけてボディーペイントをしていただき
ましたお願いします
[音楽]
うおおおお色変わってます
ああああああああああっ
[音楽]
う
今ですね上半身しか映ってないと思うん
ですけども体のすべての色が今
鉄になっております美しい
メダルボディというふうになぜこんなこと
をしたかというと味見さ蝶野さん君のお家
の庭にですね肇社長の像が置いてあるん
ですよどうですかこのフォルム現代古風し
たようなスマホ首ねっこ税なかなかスマホ
を触っているぞー世の中にないと思うん
ですけどもこれ作ってもらったんですよ
ただひとつだけは低黒光りすぐただひとつ
だけ欠点がありまして鉄で作られているの
で重すぎて運べないんですよもう私1人の
力だと到底無理音無後にかかっても結構
マジで思ってきて絶対運べないんですよ
非常に困ったずっとあそこに置いていても
嫌だなと思って移動させるためにちょっと
クレーン車を準備したので今日ようやく
あの派てミスターの層が動かせるという
ことで今日のとか田治米社長の像が本年に
なってたら気づく気付かない
[音楽]
だということをいますさあいつもために私
舌増になりました今あなたが鉄でできてい
ますそれでまず動かせないほどの重さの
鉄道を移動してもらいましょう
[音楽]
ていた
さあ出てきました
今日の舞台にはです今しっかり僕が乗る
ための台も同じ色に勉強してもらってます
そこに僕がそばいるという感じです
[音楽]
失礼しますどういう感じでこんな感じで
確か
こういう視点だけでしょ
がここからベンゼン後スマホ登ってから
スマホ持ってもらいますペットはげている
部分とか全部やって最終調整されません
自分のスマホを脱ぐわけにはいかないので
偽物事務所これも取っていきます
すげー
というわけで歓迎しましたなぁ
生前動くと剥がれるので僕あんまり動け
ないんですけどもどうでしょう
ほぼ完コピだと思いますぜひこれでの祖父
によく来る人たちをターゲットにして
バレるかバレないか継承していきたいと
おもいます
良い5
悪い
[音楽]
[拍手]
ana
me
[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
うわぁ
山
はん
どーっちかー
なんだと思ったじゃあ上から競ってくると
思うああ
パンツスカートどうぞ変わったのか人なの
かよ弱だったあっほほっきつくなかったを
リズムはすごいぞこれバレないですね
しょぼいなやばいつ結構リアル吸わず欧米
から見たらマジでをはすごいこれちょっと
次の日ても仕掛けてみましょうか
[音楽]
ああああ
ああああああああああああああああああ
ああ
そう
はい気づかなかったマジだぜうそんな
ちゃんやわけじゃないヤラセじゃないマジ
マジでマジで気づかんだマーチエキスの2
こいつをこれマジではさが一番コニーに
入れてやる肝心気すらも欺けるというこの
変わらんもんだっいつもあるそう猫いにん
[音楽]
まぁねぇ
いって
乗っていたtoo
[拍手]
ライフ
偶然性
運命
はあああああ
[拍手]
ああああああ
はぁ
うわぁ
デー
wh
まあ
お前ま
わー
[音楽]
voodooああああああ
お前はーあああああ
ラーって古馬強がること
味はしちゃうん